this is a production of Cornell
University
engaged learning is a key component of
our mission at Cornell University as we
prepare students to be creative
collaborative and critically reflective
leaders we take that really seriously in
horticulture where we engage students in
three important ways we provide students
with direct hands-on experiences we also
give students chances to apply what
they've learned in communities from the
community of the classroom to local and
global settings and we provide students
with opportunities to reflect on their
learning to consider and articulate how
they will use what they've learned to
make the world a better place as they
grow to become leaders in horticulture
so what does engaged learning look like
in horticulture let's look at some
examples students in creating the urban
Eden serve the campus community while
they learn they design and install
landscape plantings as part of their
intensive study of more than 300 species
of trees shrubs and vines including this
runoff filtering bioswale along Tower
Road we all enjoy the visual impact of
their work walking across this beautiful
campus in horticultural science and
systems students delve into many
hands-on activities from planting trees
to harvesting peppers to donating to a
local food bank they sample food remove
invasive plants from natural areas and
create textile art with plant-based dies
every fall students in restoration
ecology take on a real-world project in
the local community working together to
gather data analyze the issues and
report their findings
one year they investigated
cost-effective options for using
sediment from future dredging in the
cave the lake inlet to promote ecosystem
services the experiential learning
students gained in the field is not
separate from their classroom experience
rather it builds on it agricultural
science majors and many plant science
majors complete a summer internship to
explore career interests they apply
coursework to real-world problems and
network with growers and agricultural
professionals as well as K through 12
audiences Master Gardener volunteers and
others some create blogs to reflect on
their experiences both what they learned
and then how it changed them viticulture
and enology majors are also engaged in
all phases of growing grapes and making
wine from planting pruning and managing
a 500 vine organic vineyard near campus
to harvesting the grapes and bottling of
fruits of their labor in my course the
art of horticulture students get
first-hand experience with a range of
plant-based materials and media choosing
one for an intensive creative project in
class experiences strengthen the link to
learning and exercises and writing
encourages students to reflect on the
impact of nature and gardens on their
well-being we create public art which
may range from Assad sofa on campus to
special installations such as the
large-scale stick work willow sculpture
at the Ithaca Children's Garden budding
student researchers frequently are
guided in individual studies of their
own design by faculty mentors students
have worked with one professor to grow
vegetable transplants for distribution
to low-income family
to encourage home gardening and healthy
diets others have worked in communities
through cooperative extension programs
ranging from school garden partnerships
with elementary schools to working with
farmers and commercial growers hands on
horticulture instills non-majors with a
lifelong appreciation for plants and
teaches them basic horticultural skills
they apply techniques such as pruning to
campus landscapes and fruit trees at the
cornell orchards and students in a
Freshman Seminar have gotten their hands
dirty partnering with Habitat for
Humanity to see lawns for low-income
housing but Cornell is a global
university and the communities in which
our students work extend far beyond
Ithaca in my course experiential garden
based learning and Belize the students
spend their entire Spring Break creating
school gardens and teaching lessons that
tie the garden to the curriculum and
southern Belize so by focusing on those
three things direct experience
reflection and community engagement
we're preparing our students to become
leaders in their field in their
communities and all around the world
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu